you mentioned tyree kill and it was five
weeks ago that the Kansas City Star
first reported that there were two
incidents involving potential child
abuse as it relates to tyree kills
three-year-old son now no allegations
have been made no arrests have been made
no charges have been filed as it relates
to those two incidents but those two
incidents were extremely noteworthy for
a couple of reasons I mean first of all
it's involving a three-year-old child
and anytime there is an incident where
there's an allegation of abuse there's
an investigation there was a report by
the star that the child ended up with a
broken arm that is concerning on top of
that Tyree Cal has a history of
off-field misconduct dating back to
college where he ultimately pleaded
guilty to assaulting his then pregnant
girlfriend who was pregnant with the
same three-year-old child who was now in
the middle of this investigation in
Kansas City nothing had happened for
five weeks we didn't know what was going
on there were ending everything's
pending no news is no news as a related
Tyree kill the news came last night that
that child has been removed from the
custody of Tyree kill and his now fiance
and look that's not something that just
spontaneously happens this is the
product of multiple court hearings and
someone wearing a black robe ultimately
makes a decision that the child needs to
be for his or her own good needs to be
removed from that environment this is a
very very troubling turn for the family
for the child and for Tyree kill as it
relates to his status in the NFL because
we also know the NFL is investigating
this situation and I think at a certain
level because the NFL was never able to
take action against him for what
happened before he came to the league
that's gonna be an aggravating factor if
they ever have a basis to take action
against him for domestic violence that
is going to make it an even bigger
punishment because he escaped any type
of a suspension for what happened in
college so shereena you know when you
mentioned the if Patrick Mohammed's
gonna have Tyree kill I think it is a
big big if and at this point we just
don't know how it's all gonna unfold
yeah and my kid doesn't matter that he
wasn't arrested or anything else I you
know we saw it with Ezekiel le with the
six game suspension and I think this guy
is going to be suspended or put on the
Commissioner exemple
at some point and and I think he's not
gonna be there for at least part of the
season the Chiefs has to hope that he'll
be there for the end of the season but I
do think there is a very real
possibility that this guy is not going
to be with the Kansas City Chiefs for at
least the first half of the season and
they have to hope again that he's there
for the end of the season when they can
go to the playoffs and do what they hope
to do which is get to the Super Bowl
this year a lot would have to happen to
get to that point where he is suspended
for the start of the season and the
grand scheme of things there isn't a lot
of time to make it happen we're already
into mid to late April but what when we
consider where it is when we consider
the NFL has been investigating this for
more than a month at the NFL's letter to
the authorities in Kansas City actually
fell in between two of the incidents
that generated police reports the NFL
has been engaged and we can only assume
they are looking aggressively for any
and all evidence that there would be
reason to believe Tyreke Hill was
involved in any type of wrongdoing
directed to a three-year-old child and
Shirin this is why I think the removal
of the child from the custody of Tyreke
Hill and his fiancee is a big deal
because one of the one of the enumerated
potential violations of the personal
conduct policy when you look at the
policy there's a long list of bullet
points of things that constitute a
violation of the policy one of them
reads and I'm gonna quote it right from
the policy conduct it poses a genuine
danger to the safety and well-being of
another person you could make the
argument that whatever it was that
resulted in a judge deciding that this
child should be removed from the home
from the custody of Tyreke Hill and his
fiancee in and of itself amounts to
evidence of a genuine danger to the
safety and well-being of another person
why else would they remove the child
from the home so if the NFL wants to be
really aggressive here and we know you
mentioned a zql EA they're gonna do
whatever they want to do and they've got
they've got wide discretion to decide
when and how long to suspend someone it
would be very easy if the league wants
to do it to say that the removal of the
child from the home constitutes conduct
that poses a genuine danger to the
safety and well-being of another person
and that's a violation of the personal
conduct policy and we're going to take
action against you we're
of whether there's ever an arrest or
ever even an allegation of child abuse
against Tyreke l yeah we've just seen it
so many times they don't need that and I
know they're pursuing this aggressively
in their investigation and and we'll see
how long it takes of courses eql t it
took more than a year so I wouldn't
think this investigation probably is not
going to take that long because I think
they're going to want to do something at
some point here fairly quickly as
quickly as they can possibly do it based
on what they've heard so far it's very
troubling and I know it's troubling for
the NFL as much as it is for the Kansas
City Chiefs they don't like this kind of
stuff to come out for the NFL they don't
like their players to be involved in
this obviously and the biggest concern
is we said all along is for the son and
his safety at this point and remember
there was a report at some point in the
offseason from Jay Glazer suggesting he
had heard some trade chatter involving
Tyreke kill and that may have predated
any of these incidents coming to light
but but you just wonder how the Chiefs
already felt about Hill over the long
haul in light of whatever he was looking
for financially on his second contract
you throw these issues on top of it and
I think it's fair to wonder number one
when or if he's gonna be on the field
this season and number two if he's ever
gonna be wearing that red Chiefs helmet
again these are all things to be
determined but I can't overemphasize how
significant it is if this report from
the Kansas City Star is accurate there's
no reason to believe it isn't at this
point that the child was actually
removed from the custody of Tyreke Hill
and his fiancee
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports